get so many questions asking if i got a  job going door-to-door did not land me  any jobs but people saw the video and  reached out to me in my dm i had a  couple interning opportunities but i'm  excited to announce that i just started  my own company and i have my first  couple of customers this week i work  with people that have full-time jobs and  don't have the time to produce content  usually they want to build an online  brand but just really don't have the  time i do is i let them ramble in front  of the camera for a certain amount of  time about a topic they're passionate  about we'll edit it and make it into a  clip that you can use in all your  platforms so sorry i'm kind of sick but  yeah i'm excited